oh yeah what do you think we got in
common Oh Oh what's he wearing what's up
we're sure is the same shirt he's got
much that's not for this job you know I
really liked you I don't know if you
watch some of the previous shows that
we've done we've had some some scholars
on Joe covers a lot of good topics and I
wanted to bring this up with you because
obviously you probably listen to Joe
here and there yeah I don't know if you
got to see the programs that we did we
brought on some Muslim scholars we
academically we didn't bash Joe we
didn't put we just went and it's one
thing criticizing that's fine but there
seems to he's made some deliberate
attempts to talk about Islam and Muslims
in a negative light
for instance saying that Islam oppresses
women Islam promotes violence against
women it is it's very in in terms of
like its suppression of women's rights
and does Islam a pressure your mother
your mom wears hijab yes
is she a precedent no what would she say
right now if you asked her and she was
Joe Rogan and and Mohammed's below and
she's coming like chant a champion of
women's rights and he's saying that
eight come on take the hijab off you
you're being oppressed here in America
what would she say to him or your
sisters your sisters where he just see
what she would last she would think it's
crazy ugh you said happens at the feet
of your mom so you got a tutor mom that
at that level your mom's the highest
queen in your house no matter what so I
that's crazy al you would even think
that or say something like that yeah he
talks about acid in the face Muslim
country but even in these countries
these Islamic countries that are
throwing acid in the face she suffered
third-degree burns when her ex-boyfriend
hired another man to throw acid in her
face these people that practice the
Islamic religion to have authority would
normally motion those are the words
David Phillips will get onto him in just
a moment these Islamic countries pay the
attack happened in daylight in downtown
Vancouver Washington
I am Islamophobic said it that's true
but if it's some Imam who thinks that
you know women should cover themselves
up like they look like Jabba the Hutt or
what is it was it boba fett whichever
one whatever it is these there
I hate mail to Jo Rove it you know
assasin her disaster deface like Islam
promotes you know and he shows these
examples and trying to connect so the
average person that's a scary thing it
makes it seem it feeds into this llama
phobia like Islam and is promoting
violence is promoting the oppression of
women so now these nutjobs out there
they get this because he's got the one
of the biggest followings out there so
they hear this stuff and this I mean
it's obviously fuels the division Oh
even more in the misunderstanding and
the hate and and then you have boss a
mosque being vandalized women being
attacked and all these things so we're
trying to reach out to and we we
academically we refuted many of the the
the false statements that he had made
honor killings there's no honor in
killings this is another one what do you
have to say about that you're not a
scholar or anything but when you hear
this is just you know the regular
practicing Muslim when you hear him say
stuff like that what goes to your mind
it's nuts like he said this lamb and
generally means peace
so like when he says when people think
that or we kill because it's in our
religion or we we oppress up our family
our wives our mothers or anything like
that they're just nuts because it gives
people like a false notion and false why
should you guys forced her to wear the
head yet no they they choose to wear
that debt my sister chose to wear the
head jab when she was fifteen years old
she chose like I said my parents aren't
going to force us to do anything she she
read the Quran she she believed in it
and it she did herself that's it's a
responsibility if she wants to do it as
herself we're not gonna force anything
on it and then but like they'll see like
cultural things where you see like Saudi
Arabia old woman can't drive it like
that it has nothing to with religion
that's that's just a big problem we
actually covered that also we call that
damn if he brings up go ahead yeah
culture in that area it's not like no
woman around the world are able to know
Melissa Mormon or able to drive or get
jobs or anything like that my sister's a
pharmacist so she graduated school and
then and it has nothing to do with us
forcing her or her not being able to do
anything she did on her own yeah
beautiful so if you had a chance to you
see Joe when at the UFC dousing about
the fights I - yeah tell him I give him
our piece was tell me synonyms
hello's from us and we'd like to
hopefully I'm sure this has gotten to
him because we've done a few of them we
actually had Muhammad hijab
you know Muhammad hijab yeah yeah yeah
we had him also and we invited him to
invite him to avoid any of it we have
access to some of the top scholars in
the world okay we don't have to go
outside of America we got them here yeah
well I think that would be fair and
balanced that if he brings on a Muslim a
scholar and academic and let's go I
think the audience would love this yeah
that would not be huge yeah he gets so
many more Muslims to come in and also
his audience probably want to know
what's up with this why let's that's in
essence of keeping it fair and balanced
yeah bring up these things and let's go
ahead let's talk and these that type of
guy like I feel like he would be the be
the one to what want do that debate or
bring it on yeah yeah so what I mean
instead of bringing all of these people
you know he had someone on there let me
just show you one thing radical Islam
gets thrown around right so radical
Islam simply means I really take my
Islam seriously and now this person who
he brings on frequently it pretty much
says it pretty much if you practice
Islam that's what it translates to you
know you're pretty much a radical these
are I mean this stuff is dangerous okay
so do you take your Islam seriously yes
so that would equate that your radicals
yeah so those are kind of you know the
the things that are very laughable it
just doesn't make sense that someone
would I mean I like Joe I really I I
don't like heaven II hate I don't like
the actions that he's doing towards you
know something that yourself me and one
point seven eight billion people in the
world you know love and practice and
intellectuals who have come to Islam not
just blindly they have investigated
they've seen that the Quran is a book
from the Creator it cannot be its tamper
free tamper proof it has all the
evidence and size that is indeed from
the creator and it's just it's you know
the Harvard University has an ayah from
the Quran talking about for their law
academic Adam II these are the most
intellectual lawyers that they're
producing talking about the the ayah the
verse on justice did you know about that
not that's profound you know what I mean
yeah yeah so obviously there's
as gap that needs to be bridge and I
thought I wanted to get your thoughts on
that yeah you could send them our hellos
when you see her yeah yeah yeah sure but
like you said even my life my last fight
was last July and it was right after the
Milan but it just brought attention to
his head to when he was like because he
commentated it and he was like wait a
minute this guy train during Ramadan for
the Soul who's old camp but it just
brings like attention to it to the
public we're like now people what's
Ramadan or anything like that or Google
though they'll see what it is but like
you said if we get on that show that'd
be amazing
yeah yeah I want to thank you thank you
for coming on the Deen show a shame and
a lot less you the Creator bless you
thank you very much your honor you wanna
shout out to anybody anything not just
thank you for everybody who supports me
and where most of them were here and
there's nothing fear
I like that we're Muslim we're here
there's nothing to fear yeah um just
habla thank you my brother you thank you
so much